ce même c'était une armoire à pharmacie
typique
des années 40 50 60
j'ai vraiment des caps et jusqu'au bois
ensuite sous couche et puis trois
couches de peinture à l'extérieur comme
à l'intérieur
donner une nouvelle jeunesse à des
meubles anciens amélie en a fait sa
spécialité réparer poncet et peindre une
passion depuis 15 ans l'origine a été
par ma passion pour la décoration et mes
faibles moyens d'étudier coûte donc pour
combiner les deux je me suis mise à
récupérer des meubles et à essayer de
les refaire pour moi ça fait quelques
années que le vintage le rétro remis au
goût du jour est à la mode
j'ai l'impression vraiment que ça
s'inscrit dans la durée installés depuis
décembre à saint cyr l'école elle a
lancé son site internet la chouette
échoppes et restauration terminée ou à
venir mais aussi des créations
amélie réalise ses propres bijoux ça
c'est mes boîtes de perles en cours jeu
stoke 1 toutes les perles que je trouve
dans les brocantes chez emmaüs
le petit truc en plus ça permet de
changer et
et ça s'intègre bien dans la démarche
également rajeunir des pièces tout en
préservant leur authenticité une
démarche artistique et éco responsable
les particuliers peuvent aussi lui
demander un devis pour réactualiser
leurs meubles 100% alors